ce jeudi 20 avril au collège Joseph
Bédier à Saint-André s'est déroulé une
journée forum santé une action qui
résulte d'un travail partenarial entre
l'établissement scolaire la Maison
Départementale de Saint-André mais
également les parents d'élèves
aujourd'hui ce forum santé est dédié à
la santé de manière globale chez
l'adolescent avec 19 partenaires différ
auquel on a fait appel et avec qui on
travaille depuis 4 ans auprès des
parents pour justement répondre à ces
actes de la mandature autour de les
addictions la sexualité l'alimentation
bien-être conduite à risque et aussi la
violence les relations filles garçons
une manifestation qui répond à la
demande des parents d'élèves qui tous
les mois participent au café des parents
un groupe de paroles d'accompagnement à
la parentalité là ils tiennent des
stands ils accueent les élèves les
personnes de l'extérieur il participent
pleinement à la réalisation et à la
réussite du projet que je pense qu'il
est important en tant que parent de
s'investir dans le collège pour d'autres
parents mais surtout pour les enfants
notre génération par rapport génération
des ados il y a des choses qu'on
qu'onarrive pas à trouver facile mais
avec les professionnels qui nous
encadrent toujours on a des bons
conseils un forum qui permet aux
adolescents de trouver des réponses à
leurs questions de savoir vers qui se
tourner en cas de besoin mais également
de découvrir de nombreuses choses
l'orientation
sexuelle j'ai appris qu'il avait les
transsexuels les bisexuels les
hétérosexuels et également les h non les
homosexuels en fait nous sommes dans une
phase de croissance importante et que
nous devons avoir des informations avoir
des aides avec des psychologues et des
infirmiers et cetera et que ça peut être
très important pour nous
et pour se sentir mieux aussi une
opération réussie que l'établissement et
la Maison Départementale de Saint-André
souhait réitérer chaque
année